trapper Nipsey Hussle dead at 33
according to reports the rapper was shot
multiple times in Los Angeles on Sunday
a spokesperson for the Los Angeles
Police Department tells ET three men
were shot outside of nipsey store
marathon clothing in Hyde Park the
rapper tweeted shortly before the
incident quote having strong enemies is
a blessing
et spoke with nipsey in February at the
Grammys where he talked about being
nominated for rap album of the year I'm
inspired obviously you don't want to get
back and make some new music humbled I
know how much we put into the album so
you know to be recognized it you mean a
lot you know for my team also everybody
I worked on it
we just excited and you don't have to be
celebrities took to social media
immediately to mourn his loss
Drake posted on his Instagram quote my
whole energy is just at a low right now
hearing this LeBron James tweeted so so
sad man damn man this hurt and Rihanna
wrote my spirit is shaken by this nipsey
is survived by his two children cross
and Imani
[Music]